bonjour à tous en attendant la sortie
prochaine de nouvelles vidéos sur la
chaîne je me suis dit que ce serait pas
mal de faire une petite mise à jour
concernant le dit ce n'est plus des et
du coup tous les nouveaux projets marvel
qui ont été annoncées et c'est en
rapport du coup avec le mca comme
l'année dernière on va essayer
d'éclaircir tout ça est de voir ce qu'on
peut en tirer mais avant de commencer je
tenais à vous conseiller de vous abonner
à la chaîne si ce n'est pas déjà fait
vous êtes très nombreux à regarder les
vidéos sans être abonné donc voilà c'est
le bon moment pour le faire premièrement
j'aimerais que nous parlions des teasers
et on va commencer avec moonlight moon
knight est un héros particulier incarné
par oscar isaac moon knight s'appelle en
réalité marks spencer est considéré pour
beaucoup comme le batman de marvel à
l'origine mark était un mercenaire qui
travaillait aux côtés de rôle de
schumann pendant à red pour voler les
trouvailles de l'archéologue peter hall
ron rôle à tuer peter est sous le choc
marque s'est imposé face à ben de
schumann pour éviter un massacre
malheureusement marque sera mortellement
blessé et il bochmann tu aura finalement
quasiment tout le monde et c'est à ce
moment précis que tout va commencer car
mark est mort au pied de la statue de
comme sous le dieu de la lune ce dernier
effectuera un pacte avec marc lui
proposant de le ressusciter en échange
de devenir le chevalier de la lune
maintenant que nous y voyons plus clair
par rapport aux teaser il y a des choses
a souligné déjà nous devons parler de la
mise en scène un élément important que
je n'ai pas encore traité c'est que
marque possède un trouble de l'identité
ce dernier possède trois profils bien
distincts marks spencer qui est le
principal en quelque sorte steven grant
un riche play-boy axé sur l'aspect
financier et des cloques lit un
chauffeur de taxi
c'est pourquoi je pense que la mise en
scène nous propose beaucoup de plans
avec marc proche de miroirs ou d'objets
qu'ils puissent le refléter toujours
avec un minimum de reflets permettant de
traduire ces deux autres identités qui
le regarde en revanche par le biais de
sa nouvelle identité en tant que moon
knight et bien cela montre le nombre de
profils à 4 et c'est pourquoi dans la
mise en scène le nombre de reflets passe
de 2 à 3 quand il est en mode knight et
pour continuer sur ce fameux troubles de
l'identité cela permet l'ambiguïté de
l'existence véritable de canso puisque
marque souffre de son trouble il a du
mal à détecter si cette voix dans sa
tête est une illusion ou une véritable
personne de ce que nous avons réellement
sur la série mark spencer sort est un
boxeur et un militaire de l'armée
américaine mais le plus intéressant
qu'il est dit par le biais du synopsis
que marks spencer et ses identités vont
se retrouver dans une guerre meurtrière
des dieux d'égypte dans un contexte
moderne et ancien évidemment comme sow
n'est pas le seul dieu d'égypte et
d'après le synopsis cela pourrait
vouloir dire que d'autres dieux sont en
conflit avec comme sous et choisiraient
également leur champion pour les temps
modernes mais cela reste une supposition
par rapport à cette description le roi
soleil pourrait être un vilain adéquat
puisqu'il est la représentation damon
aura une divinité d'égypte père de canso
et rival de ce dernier le soleil face à
la lune néanmoins le cab buchmann reste
toujours intéressant car il est
l'antagoniste emblématique de moonlight
liée à son origin story et on peut
également mentionner le fait que blade
serait apparemment attendu pour faire
une apparition dans la série ce qui
inclurait également des menaces liées à
ce dernier comme dracula pour certains
mais bon rien n'est véritablement
confirmé enfin qu est ce qu on pourrait
rajouter de plus en soit si le teaser de
la série semble proposer quelque chose
de plus sombre qu'à l'habitude et c'est
aussi parce que moonlight est un héros
sombre ce dernier agit toujours de nuit
évidemment vu qu'il est le chevalier de
la lune c'est cohérent et surtout
n'hésite pas à tuer de sang froid et de
façon violente si c'est nécessaire sans
oublier aussi que quand sow est
peut-être le dieu de la lune mais il est
aussi considéré comme le dieu de la
vengeance continuons maintenant sur
chiottes nous retrouvons jennyfer
walters une avocate et cousines de bruce
banner que nous connaissons tous en tant
que lyc de par son origine story des
comics nous devrions retrouver la même
histoire dans sa série par rapport au
petit teaser en gros jennifer walters en
tant qu'avocate a été victime dune
représailles car elles défendent est un
gangster qui travaillait pour un grand
chef criminel étant entre la vie et la
mort la seule solution a été que son
cousin bruce lui donne son sang pour une
transfusion sanguine
le synopsis de la série semble
d'ailleurs approuvé cette
retranscription évidemment le résultat a
donné naissance à she hulk
c'est pourquoi elle possède les mêmes
aptitudes que son cousin concernant la
série en elle-même il faut s'attendre
apparemment à une épopée de dix épisodes
de 30 minutes est dans le style comédie
juridique ce choix de comédie n'est pas
très surprenant car she hulk est une
héroïne qui fait beaucoup d'humour et
plus que ça encore elle brise très
souvent le quatrième mur comme deadpool
et c'est un élément qui est attendu dans
la série c'est pourquoi dans le teaser
elle semble s'adresser à nos spectateurs
cela explique également ce petit spot
humoristique où elle affirme qu'il ne
faut pas lui faire peur sous peine de le
regretter néanmoins il ya un autre point
très important a souligné présent dans
le teaser et qui symbolise clairement le
personnage de chiottes c'est que
l'avocate s'assume complètement sous sa
forme verte dites vous que dans les
comics elle préfère même sa forme she
hulk à sa forme humaine c'est un élément
qui va expliquer pourquoi son évolution
sera aussi rapide contrairement à banner
qui rejetait hulk et avaient du mal à
cohabiter avec son pouvoir chirac assume
complètement cette forme et l'acceptent
et il semble à coup sûr que l'on valeurs
retrouvées dans la série maintenant si
on s'intéresse au casting tim roth sera
de retour en tant qu abomination bon
soit mais le plus intéressant est la
présence de jameela jamil en tant que
titania la plus grande antagonistes de
l'histoire de she wolf le souci étant
que titania de son vrai nom marie
macfarlane devient ce qu'elle est grâce
au docteur doom par le biais du battle
world c'est un peu compliqué à expliquer
mais ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que
c'est beaucoup trop tôt et trop abstrait
pour le mc eu notamment du fait que
doctor doom n'est pas encore introduit
il ya vraiment vraiment trop trop peu de
chances pour qu'il le soit avec she hulk
en revanche marie pourrait essayer de
s'injecter la même transfusion sanguine
que jennifer pour devenir titania ce qui
me fait penser ceci c'est que dans
l'histoire de mary cette dernière était
une jeune fille qui a subi du
harcèlement elle a toujours été moquée
et insulté et pour contrer ça elle s'est
fait passer pour spider woman afin de
devenir populaire ce qui marchera un
certain temps avant que le mensonge soit
découvert mais ce qui est intéressant
ici c'est que mairie cherche à devenir
populaire et même une héroïne pour
justement se venger de ce qu'elle a subi
toute sa vie c'est pourquoi dans une
modification cohérente de son histoire
elle pourrait chercher à obtenir le sens
de banner et cela équilibre est du coup
les combats à venir à entre elles et she
hulk d'ailleurs dans une idée d'
équilibre et de fan service
l'abomination pourrait se battre à ses
côtés pour faire du deux contre deux et
qui sait peut-être que jennifer a causé
du tort à marie étant plus jeune pour
lui donner une envie de se venger bref
j'avoue on spécule de ouf mais voilà sur
quoi on peut s'en tenir pour le moment
enfin le dernier teaser nous a montré
des images inédites de miss marvel alors
en vrai de vrai ce teaser comme pour
chiots lq propose plus un visuel de ce
qu'on va avoir dans la série que deux
heures vl nouvelles informations on
retrouve bien évidemment calmes à la can
qui est une jeune fille de 16 ans
d'origine pakistanaise et qui est une
grande fan de captain marvel la série
comportera six épisodes néanmoins la
question la plus intéressante concernant
ce teaser est le mystère entourant son
pouvoir car pour ceux qui ne le savent
peut-être pas ils seront réadaptées dans
le mc en fait dans les comics kamala
possède un héritage génétique provenant
d inhumain et c'est ce qui va lui
octroyer ces pouvoirs qui sont
symbolisés surtout par l'élasticité et
la guérison pour le moment il n'y a rien
de véritablement confirmé mais par
rapport à sa future liaison avec monica
rambo et carole denver et la cohérence
du fait qu'il n'y a pas d' inhumain dans
le mc eu sans oublier l'image
promotionnelles que nous avions de la
série et bien il se pourrait que kamala
se servent d'un artefact lié à l'énergie
cosmique pour générer ces pouvoirs et ce
qui me fait aller dans ce sens également
et que pour le moment malgré les teasers
où nous avons vu mouna est en action
shulk sous sa vraie forme et bien kamala
ne nous a pas montré d'élasticité
notamment avec son célèbre point qu'elle
fait grossir comme un marteau mais en
revanche nous avons retrouvé les codes
visuels de l'énergie cosmique qui
symbolise carroll ou encore monica avoir
du coup qu'elle sera l'origine exacte de
ses pouvoirs on continue avec l'unique
image qui nous a été proposé sur secret'
inve jeunes on retrouve un nick fury
avec une grosse barbe et samson
cache-oeil en vrai on sait encore très
peu de choses sur secretin les jeunes
mais ça a quand même évolué depuis un an
déjà par rapport aux dates de sortie
puisque la série sort normalement en
2022 et comportera six épisodes
également on se doute que c'est la suite
de far from home le moment où l'on
retrouvé nick fury dans l'espace et par
rapport à wanda vision nous avons la
confirmation qu'il se trouverait
toujours là haut pour rappel secretin
les jeunes parlent d'une invasion
secrète des scroll sur terre pour se
cacher des cris suite à une lourde
défaite évidemment c'est quelque chose
qui va créer la paranoïa chez nos héros
puisque plus personne n'arrivera à se
faire confiance car tout simplement pas
n'importe qui pourrait être un skrull en
fait évidemment il y aura beaucoup de
réécriture et d'adaptation pour coller
avec le mc eu et cela promet quelque
chose d'intéressant par rapport à nyc
fiori qui travaille avec talent hausse
depuis maintenant des années et avec
d'autres skrull sur le vaisseau du sword
néanmoins nous pouvons parler aussi du
casting puisque nous retrouverons par
exemple emilia clarke olivia colman
kingsley banadir kylie ann scott ou
encore christopher mcdonald on se doute
que chacun aura un rôle important et
plusieurs possibilités existent ce que
je veux dire c'est qu'il pourrait jouer
une réadaptation des sicre et warriors
de fiori par exemple ou tout simplement
des personnages liés aux sword qui
d'ailleurs n'a pas encore été développés
donc cela expliquerait ces nouveaux
personnages mais possiblement aussi des
skrulls c'est le cas par exemple de
kingsley qui est prévu pour jouer à un
antagoniste ce dernier pourrait incarner
pourquoi pas le super skrull qui est
possiblement le vilain le plus connu
parmi le peuple scroll dans tous les cas
la série va mettre en lumière le peuple
scroll et nick fury donc il faut
certainement s'attendre à avoir de
grosses têtes de lempire scroll avec du
coup pourquoi pas talos qui affronterait
ces derniers depuis la terre tandis que
nick fury serez face aux dirigeants de
cette invasion depuis l'espace c'est une
idée comme une autre et on termine
rapidement sur les nouveaux logos celui
de ces crétine va jeunes a évolué pour
passer d'un rouge vif à du verre avec
des morceaux de violer nul doute que
c'est pour représenter la couleur des
skrulls et leur pouvoir de métamorphose
nous avons toujours la présence d'iam
group et le special holidays des
gardiens de la galaxie rien de nouveau
par rapport à ça si ce n'est qu'on peut
mentionner qu adam warlock a été castée
pour les gardiens de la galaxie 3
évidemment what i fé lo qui auront une
saison 2 c'est très attendu et confirmé
toute façon je vous avoue que loki
saison 2 est l'une des choses que
j'attends le plus en revanche petite
nouveauté une série eco a été annoncé
écho de son vrai nom maya lopez est une
héroïne de chez marvel elle est attendue
à faire une apparition dans la série 2
hawkeye et du coup cela permettrait de
tizé son propre spin off pour faire
simple écho est une jeune fille dont le
père travaillait pour wilson fisk oui le
criminel de spider man sauf que fils que
tuera le père de maya et la prendra sous
son aile pour la forme est alors
évidemment de par les accords entre
marvel et sony je pense que l'histoire
sera réadapté pour qu'elle soit adoptée
par une autre menace qu'a un méchant
iconique de spider man étant donnée son
apparition dans hawkeye elle pourrait
pourquoi pas être la disciple du clown
qui serait le vilain 2 hawkeye c'est
très dur à définir pour le moment
concernant ses aptitudes maya est sourde
et c'est reproduire à la perfection les
mouvements de son adversaire un peu
comme taskmaster mais le plus
intéressant et qu'elle est très liée à
matt murdock alias daredevil dans son
histoire la série eco pourrait être donc
une introduction pour le personnage s'il
n'apparaît pas déjà dans nos et home et
c'est un peu le cas également pour she
hulk matt murdock pourrait apparaître là
bas et enfin les deux derniers petits
nouveaux sont des séries dédié à marvel
zombies pied agatha harkness marvel
zombies est attendu pour être une série
animée effectivement cela fait sens
quand on sait que l'origine de la série
vient de what if en vrai la réalité de
marvel où les zombies ont pris le
pouvoir et possiblement le motif le plus
connu l'univers des comics je ne suis
pas trop surpris de voir une adaptation
en animation à voir en tout cas quel
impact cela aura sur le mc ou mais comme
toujours on aura des surprises puis la
série agathe harkness mattrick pas mal
je vous avoue effectivement malgré la
défaite d'agata dans one la vision et
bien c'était sûr qu'elle allait revenir
un jour ou l'autre luanda la juste
emprisonné en quelque sorte hélas le
fait de produire une origine story au
personnage indique clairement qu'elle
aura son importance et étoffer son
background va servir à mieux cerner son
personnage pour l'avenir de par ses
récentes productions marvel semble
commencer à s'intéresser à tous les
aspects historiques de l'univers par le
biais et d'agata nous pourrions voir le
développement des sorcières de salem
donc une histoire qui se passerait loin
dans le passé mais surtout cela va
permettre d'ajouter du background odarc
old savoir comment agatha a mal tourné
il se pourrait que ce soit à cause du
livre étant donné que le dark auld est
réputé pour rendre fou son lecteur et du
coup comment elle a réussi aussi à se
procurer le livre il y a une chance
d'avoir des éléments sur les grands
anciens comme octobre qui est l'auteur
du livre dans les comics et pourquoi pas
shuma gorath qui a déjà commencé à
apparaître timidement enfin voila
c'était une vidéo dédiée aux nouvelles
annonces du disney puces des et puis bah
j'espère que cela vous aura plus alors
on n'a pas parlé de toutes les annonces
mais je voulais me concentrer
principalement sur le mc eu et tout ce
qui est lié à l'univers etc je pense que
c'était pas mal de faire une petite mise
à jour et puis en plus de ça ça nous a
permis de spéculer un petit peu et de
faire des petites théorie donc voilà si
la vidéo vous a plu n'hésitez pas à
laisser un petit pouce bleus à vous
abonner à la chaîne c'est très important
et surtout à me dire en commentaire quel
projet vous a le plus hype et parmi les
nouvelles annonces moi je vous avoue que
ce serait pourquoi pas plutôt moon
knight qui m'attire le plus pour le
moment et puis bah écoute et que le lay
rares soit avec vous cet argot rock
allez ciao tout le monde
[Musique]